- No one needs to hack into my phone
to find out how fucked up I am.
I put that on the internet for free.
- I probably should be more concerned,
but honestly I don't think
I ever think about it.
- I'm not actively worried about people
listening to my conversations.
Like the government tapping into my phone,
but I know that, I think it was Steve Jobs
covered up the camera on his laptop, but
it doesn't plague me everyday.
- I am in constant fear I
am totally gonna get fucked
one day, but I'm also
someone who watches porn on
their work computer, so I
guess I'm not that concerned.
- Yeah
- Whoa!
- Someone with physical access
to your phone can download
spying software from the
internet onto your phone.
- I don't think I knew that.
Hence, the surprise in my voice.
- But they have to be
physically next to my phone, so
I have my phone in my pocket
24/7 so I'm not too worried
about that one.
- This software gives the
hacker access to turn on your
camera, read your text messages.
- Including deleted messages,
listen to your phone calls,
and find your location.
Now that's scary.
- Whaaat? What!?
- That's not good. I have
some texts I would prefer
remain hidden.
- It is also possible to
get hacked by accidentally
downloading "malicious
profiles", also known as malware.
It can be sent to your
phone via a link through
a text message, email, or
complimentary Wi-Fi access?
That's fuckin' rude!
- I don't like when, on my
computer, a pop-up will come up
and be like "your computer
is compromised. Click here to
download the thing, and
then that's the thing that's
gonna hurt you, like everyone's
a fuckin' liar on the
internet.
- Malware can track keystrokes
and control the hacking
device, including reading
and deleting emails, changing
contact details, and tap into phone calls.
- Can track keystrokes? Damn!
- Come on? You cannot detect
malware on your phone.
Okay, so how am I even
supposed to know that my phone
has an STD?
- Always update your software
to the latest version as soon
as you can.
I never update.
- Some may have found ways
to gain access to information
without entering a passcode at all.
- Do not click on strange links
that have either been sent
to you by email or text, fuckin' duh.
Do not open suspicious emails
or attachments. Bye, I know
- Obviously, if you don't
know who sent it to you,
don't open it. I'm talkin to you, Gramma.
- Do not perform sensitive
activity on external, public,
or insecure Wi-Fi networks.
Well, I've already fucked
that up, because I watch porn
on my work computer.
- Utilize two-step authentication. I do!
- Put tape over your camera.
- Yeah, man, I need to get
some tap on my camera like ASAP
- I feel like that's silly
to walk around with tape, but
I don't want anyone seeing me.